[Music]
[Applause]
hey folks welcome to the Dark Horse
podcast live stream number 174. I am Dr
Brett Weinstein this is Dr Heather
heying we are in our seats Despite All
Odds and uh much chaos but nonetheless
we're we're ready to go we are ready to
go 174 unlike 173 is neither prime nor
sexy
it is neither prime nor sexy nor
perfect which is a term that I learned
this morning that mathematicians use to
Hype certain numbers that they like
because of the fact that you can add
their factors and get them to sum up to
the numbered question or something like
that feels like you're uh you're casting
aspersions on mathematicians and
suggesting that they live in the social
world where all you have to do is name
things something and uh and then we'll
feel differently about those things
which exist whether or not we've given
them names now
I believe I do not know this may be
apocryphal it is almost certainly
misattributed but
um and I may even have mentioned it
before but I believe the ultimate
aspersion has been properly cast and
will never be exceeded when it comes to
mathematicians
um it is frequently attributed to Darwin
who
almost certainly did not say that a
mathematician is like a blind man in a
dark room looking for a black cat that
isn't there
which I think you can't beat an
aspersion like that I mean that is just
Wicked it doesn't sound like Darwin
though no it doesn't sound like Darwin I
don't know frankly I would think he was
you know maybe not super enthused with
the math side of things but he would
certainly be friendly to it yeah I know
he was just sort of a very gentle easy
going guy there's that too yeah he had a
he had a bulldog for a reason exactly
fellow ape who could do who'd say that
sort of thing absolutely I'm stopping to
hot water well here we are it is uh it
is May 20th well my notes still say May
30th I am a week behind the times
and
um we've got new things coming soon new
platforms new plans uh and we're also
going to start doing Q and A's only
twice a month so we're not going to do
one this week but we will next week and
uh it will will make it easy for you to
figure out where to find all of that
um but you may want to find a cubby or
something in which to put cues that have
to wait a week for them to uh to meet up
with A's and we wonder sometimes
internally why people have a hard time
figuring out how to do what we are
asking them to do
we
we do Wonder no we really don't no we
really don't
um you don't no nor does our producer
sitting over there in the corner
um okay so we do have the private q a
though um on my patreon once a month as
well and the question asking period for
that is open as of last night so if you
if you like and those are those feel
different those are little those are
smaller we pay attention to the chat we
engage with the chat uh so if you if you
join uh us at my patreon uh you can you
can get access to that you can also find
weekly usually weekly writings from me
at Natural Selections that not that's
natural selections.substack.com this
week I wrote a piece called it's not too
late about
um about the realization that is Dawning
on many people who have been following
the science who bought into the
pronouncements and the promises that if
you just do what we tell you to do uh
you too will be freed from the shackles
that we have put you in and uh
increasingly I and we are running into
people who acknowledge yeah there is
certainly a lot of heart problems and
Cancers and um
and even babies are getting myocarditis
I ran into this morning and that does
that does seem to be uh potentially
related to the things that the MRNA
treatments which I am increasingly
loathe to call vaccines because they are
not uh that were rolled out fast and
furious and we were assured we're safe
and effective and as we've talked about
almost endlessly here before there was
no way to know that they were safe and
therefore one had to wonder if the claim
that they were effective which was
sitting right next to the known lie safe
could also perhaps not be true and of
course as it turns out they're not so
it's not too late this week on my on my
substack at Natural Selections I
encourage you to join me there free
subscribers get access to almost
everything paying subscribers get
additional perks like some audio reads
from me and a few additional written
pieces and the ability to comment on
posts you want to say something yeah I
do
um I as you know have been uh a go go go
traveling and not had a chance to read
your piece yet so it's possible that
this is redundant but I feel it is
always worth saying in the context of
it's not too late that everything we
know about the types of damage that we
see
suggests it's cumulative and therefore
not only is it not too late in the sense
that there's still something to salvage
but there is every reason to think that
uh if you
have shown no symptoms of anything so
far that's stopping now is potentially
the key to to Future Health so
absolutely and I think um that that is
absolutely true my uh the tenor of the
piece is more about
uh
uh the the social and behavioral aspects
of of belief so it's you know as I
finish the piece but it's not too late
to change your mind right and if you do
and if you have vilified people
you owe them that acknowledgment
and
um
even if you did not vilify people as so
many did if you do change your mind just
try in the you know the the many among
the many other things that everyone is
no doubt doing
uh to be a bit more aware and awake to
what you're being told and assured of
that is coming in under the guise of
expert guidance
uh that perhaps is no such thing
we've seen it in in abundance in the
last over three years now but of course
it is happening all the time and
increasingly uh when you are told just
do this thing we've looked into it it's
behind closed doors don't worry about it
we got your back they probably don't
have your back
yeah I think
um
something is in the air I don't know if
you're noticing it as well but what
happened with
um
with crystal ball and and uh Bobby
Kennedy Jr and the reaction to it to me
is actually quite heartening the
fraction of the world that is now awake
to something is quite large and so
I'm beginning to
I'm beginning to feel like the
assessment that we get from looking at
the the world as it's presented to us of
what it is that people believe is so
wildly off that you're better off to
just discount it and you know I agree
and I don't know what you're talking
about I was also traveling this week and
I don't I did not pay attention to most
of the stuff happening on social media
but um but yes it does feel like there's
a lot a lot in in the air let's before
we embark on that let's just get through
the rest of the top of the
top of the hour and get to our sponsors
and then and then start talking in
Earnest
um we have darks darkhorsestore.org
which is through a print shop who makes
all of our merchandise
um right here in the United States it's
a it's a couple a couple of American
entrepreneurs
um who both uh create the products and
run the shop and so supporting
darkhorsestore.org with products like
Pfizer the breakthroughs never stop
supports not just us but uh but them and
and they will never censor us unlike the
previous outfit that we sold our
merchandise at we have
um we are supported by our audience we
appreciate you subscribing liking um by
this time next week there will be uh
more places to find us and we look
forward to talking about that then but
you can also so subscribe like share
videos at the moment on YouTube and on
Odyssey and through Apple podcast
Spotify all of that
and to support us in another way
consider joining one of our patreons
where Brett has some monthly
conversations and on his and we have a
private monthly conversation on mine and
we also have access to the Discord
server where this conversation is taking
place all the time and uh one of the
things that the Discord server gives you
access to is is they figure out each
time that we have a q a in advance which
question or question is they'd most like
us to answer and we start off all of our
q and A's that way and they are um
reliably excellent questions honestly so
all of that is happening uh through our
patreons and then of course we have
sponsors all of whom have products that
we actually vouch for or have close
friends uh who vouch for them if they
make a product that we don't that we
can't assess ourselves so three sponsors
at the top of the hour as always here we
go okay our first sponsor this week is
Seoul s-o-l-e who make custom multiple
footbeds for inside your shoes providing
affordable pain relief since 2001.
sole footbeds include a signature
supportive Arch which is clinically
proven to reduce Arch strain in your
feet and these footbeds are great for
any Arch height if you have low arches
or flat feet you simply heat mold them
in your oven at home to ensure a
comfortable level of support
that is all true anecdotally I will say
that Soul footbeds have been a game
changer for me
I was born with weird feet weird enough
that I had reconstructive surgery on
them when I was 13 which put me in a
wheelchair for months and truly ugly
orthopedic shoes for a year
that surgery was extremely successful
such that I was playing Varsity Sports
within a couple years after that but
it's been a while since I was 13 and my
arches are beginning to flatten and my
feet hurt a lot more than they used to
wearing shoes with sole footbeds in them
is helping tremendously I've just
started doing this in the last couple of
months and it is like I said a game
changer I have sole footbeds in my extra
tough boots and my hiking boots and even
in a pair of shoes that you might go to
a nice restaurant in the kind of shoes
that I wear less often than the other
kinds of shoes but they work in all
sorts they have multiple styles for
different kinds of activity if you have
any foot issues at all you should
seriously try these footbeds
so all footbeds are easily customizable
as I already said using your oven at
home
and you put them in the oven for a
couple minutes and you put them in your
shoes and you just stand still in your
shoes for I think it's five minutes and
then they're really they're personalized
and it's like having a custom orthotic
at a tiny fraction of the price and
excuse me you can buy them off the rack
effectively not that you put footbeds on
a rack but I don't know how they make
them maybe they do uh
footbeds interact but not weapons of
mass destruction yeah it's a different
rack but uh yeah different rack yeah
um and that's how I heard it okay yeah
the dog is starting back there so maybe
it's how she heard it as well the dog
who's only who's rump we can see at the
moment she's turned the wrong way
um they're made from recycled cork too
which is cool uh so Soul footbeds also
reduce pain from plantar fasciitis and
shin splints they promote neutral
alignment and good posture and are
particularly effective at preventing
fatigue when standing or walking for
long hours on hard surfaces
two-thirds of people who try sole
footbeds come back for a second pair and
many have trusted soul to keep their
feet energized and pain-free for more
than 20 years I'm using three pairs of
them at the moment and they're all great
if you've ever wondered whether
Orthotics could add to your comfort or
athletic performance this is your chance
to find out what 16 million satisfied
Souls s-o-l-e's already know as a dark
horse listener you can now try soul
footbeds for free for 30 days simply go
to yoursoul.com Darkhorse or enter the
code Darkhorse at checkout to receive
any pair of footbeds with no charge for
the first 30 days your credit card will
be charged 30 days after your order
ships and if you don't love your
footbeds simply return them before the
30 days 30 days are up and you won't be
charged at all that's your soul why are
you r s o l e.com slash Darkhorse or
enter the code darkhorset checkup for
any pair of footbeds on yoursoul.com try
soil free today and say goodbye to sore
feet yeah I have also been using the
footbeds which I did not do at first I
loved the couple pairs of shoes that I
had and I've uh I've I've really used
them a lot especially when traveling and
eating something a little fancier the
um the fit is fantastic but I've started
upgrading other shoes that I have
occasion for like I've even upgraded
some extra tough boots you know here
I'll say that I had done that myself
sorry I missed that part but yeah the
upgraded rubber boots like you wouldn't
think a rubber boot you know you know
I've done a lot of walking in rubber
boots and um it's often a sloppy
experience but you can upgrade them with
these things and it's as you know I I we
spent a week in Alaska recently and I
was mostly wearing my extra tough soles
in them and they were amazing
okay our second sponsor this week is new
to us this month cured Keurig makes no
tropics and a market increasingly full
of such products but cured sent to
several of their lines and I have tried
and benefited from many of them
I want to specifically talk about their
product called rise designed to be taken
in the morning or whenever mental
Clarity energy and focus is your desired
State rise was formulated by carrad's
own in-house clinical herbalist I've
tried it several times and each time
find a subtle but definitely noticeable
difference in my tendency to stay on
task and get things done quickly and
efficiently I truly appreciate it
ingredients in Rise include lion's mane
for mental Clarity and energy cordyceps
to enhance oxygen utilization CBD and
ginseng and huperzia Serrata a Club Moss
that has been used in Chinese herbal
medicine to alleviate memory loss and
reduce inflammation and derivatives of
the same Club Moss have begun to be used
in Western medicine to treat Alzheimer's
disease
cured's rise blend of functional
mushrooms adaptogens and cannabinoids
will leave your brain on fire that's
their line but I need to say in a good
way because you don't normally want your
brain to be better for your brain than
your pants
nope I think I'd rather have my pants on
fire yeah especially if I'm not wearing
it with the time on the internet that is
considered a fatal indictment yeah it's
on fire but yeah PolitiFact or whatever
it is yes yes okay let's after this
um
Verizon's plan to functional mushrooms
adaptogens the cannabinoids will leave
your will help you get your to-do list
tackled how about that I'll still lie
the brain on fire but the values that
Kieran holds highest are in nature
responsibility and Service as they say
on the website quote we are more than
just our products we are stewards of the
plants we represent Health as a
combination of movement mindfulness and
daily action
cured also does 30 part 30.
third party testing 30 party testing
would be a little excessive I think
carrot also does third party testing off
all of their hemp derived CBD products
and makes those test results available
on its site such testing is not a legal
requirement but allows customers to be
certain that curd products are free of
harmful contaminants like pesticides and
heavy metals which is always a concern
uh with uh with products where you're
not sure exactly what you're getting
rise is only one of many of Keira's
products they also make Zen a product
designed for afternoons and evenings a
sleep bundle that incorporates CBD with
their Zen product and so many more they
are so likely to have the nootropic that
is right for you
right now carrot is extending an
exclusive offer to you our listeners you
can get rise or any of kirid's other
fantastic products for 20 off by
visiting
www.curednutrition
c-u-r-e-dnutrition.com Dark Horse and
using coupon code Dark Horse at checkout
that's
c-u-r-e-dnutrition.com
Darkhorse and use coupon code Darkhorse
at checkout to save 20 percent
now our final sponsor Heather it will
not surprise you to discover is feed a
probiotic that really works your gut and
your immune system work together
coordinating your body's response to the
world
oh you're not talking about just me no
no no no no no no not just you it's a
more General uh your gut and everyone
else's uh and their immune systems work
together coordinating their body's
response it's very hard for me now to
edit this I'm going to go back to your
your gut and your immune system like
everybody else's work together
coordinating the body's response to the
world both around and within you seed
helps improve the health of your gut
biome and anyone else so uses it which
means that it supports you becoming a
healthier person overall as with others
our resident gut microbiops directly
impact the development and function of
the immune system even before we're born
microbes inform the immune system
teaching your body how to distinguish
between benign substances and pathogenic
antigens that is substances our body
doesn't recognize as its own you can
support your gut immune axis that is the
Axis of Awesome in a variety of ways
including by prioritizing your sleep
your body operates on a 24-hour cycle
known as your circadian rhythm new
research suggested gut microbiomes have
their own circadian clock and that
changes the normal rhythms which can be
disrupted if your microbes are off
prioritizing regular insufficient sleep
can thus help keep your gut immune axis
healthy again the Axis of Awesome
foreign
but I'm having a good time so you can
also support your gut immune axis by
taking seeds
ds-01 daily symbi syn biotic
synbiotic seed is a plant-based
Prebiotic and probiotic teas you
designed this to trip me up didn't you
it's a top of my product I love it I
love it but I since the name is a little
is a little bit seed is a plant-based
Prebiotic and probiotic with 24 strains
that have been clinically or or
scientifically studied for their
benefits I get it I see the distinction
clinically versus scientifically it's
perfectly well stated thank you 16 of
those 24 strains are specifically geared
towards Digestive Health as you would
expect for from a probiotic and four of
the 24 probiotic strains are known to
promote healthy skin your skin like your
gut has its own microbiome seed supports
both gut and skin Health seed is free
from 14 major classes of allergens
including but not limited to sugar
animal products soy gluten peanut
glyphosate Dairy shellfish and corn and
seed is basically a is double hold that
is the structure of the capsule it is
engineered to maintain viability through
through your digestive tract until it
reaches your colon where you want it and
the same design makes it resistant to
oxygen moisture and heat meaning that no
Refrigeration is necessary
seeds daily symbiotic support supports
gut and skin and heart health
micronutrient and micronutrient
synthesis
we have heard from several people who
have used seed and Report improvements
to their digestive function in 24 to 48
hours
you and I have both used it and had
excellent results
so start a new healthy habit visit
seed.com Dark Horse and use the code
Darkhorse to redeem 25 off your first
month of seeds ds-01 daily symbiotic
that's seed.com
Darkhorse and use the code Darkhorse at
checkout
you did
um
all right uh shall I start or should you
start today
um why don't you start all right
uh
the press secretary Kareem Jean-Pierre
got
into trouble with conservatives this
week as she is what to do
when she and Fox News as it is want to
do I took her to task you may show my
screen here Zach
um
Fox News tweeted quoting
Karim Jean-Pierre in which he was
talking about bands on trans treatment
for minors
she said these are our kids they belong
to all of us
if I may have my screen back now
these are our kids they belong to all of
us and many people online conservatives
I expect
had a predictable meltdown as a result
of this not today Satan
the dumbs are communists they're saying
the quiet part out loud right these were
some of the kinds of responses that she
got for uh for and this is just based on
that one tweet from Fox I'm sure there
was all sorts of other similar stuff all
over the web
but
don't think the conservatives have it
right either
because
um the press secretary while objectively
wrong at one level right
these kids aren't all of ours you know
our producer sitting over there is not
your child he's our child and he's never
going to be anyone else's child right
even as he's not a child anymore he's
still our Offspring our child
but it's also true that the children
are our future
and that sounds blue and silly but it's
true collectively we owe it to the
children we owe it to the children not
just our children but all of the
children do not let them destroy
themselves we do
we also owe them a functional world and
this is part of why people like us are
interested in preserving and conserving
natural resources and wildness so that
people in the future can have a world in
which it is possible to actually see
wildness and and learn something from it
and the madness
masquerading as care and kindness
in trans activism world that is puberty
blockers and cross-sex hormones and
surgeries for minors
is something that we as a society
are obligated to protect our children
from
so we have a quandary right both sides
both sides in this and just this really
does seem to fall into sides but it's
not left versus right
it's not it's not liberal versus
conservative both sides in these should
children be allowed to medically
transition to appear more like the sex
they are not
yes that's the language of our side uh
debate that is both sides in the should
we let children decide
to stop development and then start
taking cross-sex hormones and have
surgery that is irreversible
both sides in that debate seem to truly
believe that they are on the right side
of History
all right that this is about protecting
children I'm sure there are people on
both sides I know there are people on
the side whom the press secretary Kareem
Jean-Pierre thinks she is representing
who are acting cynically and are not
working on behalf of children and
presumably there's people on on both
sides who aren't but uh mostly people
really do think that they are advocating
for an underrepresented disempowered
group that needs their support
on both sides of this and
frankly for uh conservatives to forget
that they also care about all children
in order to you know dump on the press
secretary for making a claim that the
children belong to all of us
uh is a little disingenuous and a little
hypocritical even though I get it like I
understand that the response is you know
standing oh no no no say the whole hell
away from my children right but we do
really have a quandary here because we
as people who are liberal in almost all
of our beliefs but who absolutely are
certain that children need to be
protected from their fantasies and their
delusions and their social contagion and
not be allowed
to block their own puberty
and thus cause themselves or or
certainly any of the things farther down
that road and thus cause themselves a
life long
medicalization that may have yielded
infertility among many other problems
we are certain in fact
as presumably are the people on the
other side that were on the right side
of history and that we're protecting
people
so what do we do it's not so simple it's
not a not today Satan
question
um
I wanna
argue that
the conversation that you're trying to
have is obviously exactly the right one
but
the when I see that quote deployed by
Fox apparently quoting the press
secretary accurately as to what she said
I have the sense that something else is
going on
um can we then do that after I finish
talking about this sure I mean unless
nope I can keep it um
so
you know we We've Ended up talking about
trans activism a lot on Dark Horse and
I've written about it a lot and we uh
have always been careful to distinguish
it from what we call true trans which is
an exceedingly rare condition uh which
in a few cases may actually be genetic
such as in a little village in the
Dominican Republic
and in a few cases uh maybe due to
developmental things that happened in
utero for instance but it is exceedingly
rare and increasingly this conversation
I'm certain
is not about it's not about those people
by and large who want to stay out of the
Limelight and want to be left alone to
live the lives that they need to live in
order to be their best selves
the vast majority of what is passing for
Trans right now
uh is comprises this Resurgence of
regressive gender norms
that will reinforce disempowering
Lifestyles for women that's one
social contagion mental delusion or some
combination of all three so let me just
talk about these three briefly
with regard to regressive gender norms
if you're a man
you should feel free to be a sensitive
poet who likes to dress in flowy clothes
and discuss your feelings for hours over
tea and scones or wine and ice cream or
whatever it is you want to discuss it
over right and do that be that guy
do not mistake this for being a woman
doesn't make you a woman
makes you a guy who doesn't fit into
traditional gender Norms that's fine
you're a guy you're a man
if you're a woman
be free actually be free to be a
risk-taking electrician perhaps who does
not want to answer the question how are
you feeling today like ever Maybe
don't mistake that for being a man
you're a woman who doesn't fit into
traditional gender norms
and I've said this many many times when
we were growing up in the 70s and 80s
that was increasingly fine
I was a girl and became a young woman
who did not fit traditional gender norms
and I was lucky to have parents who
thought that was just fine
and if I were growing up today
my desire to never wear dresses and when
I was put in a dress to get it pretty
dirty because I was outside playing in
the mud
um
would have resulted in someone perhaps
privately at school informing me that
probably what I was revealing was that I
wasn't a girl at all but that I was a
boy no wrong I never mistook myself for
a boy
and I'm also not as some number of
people who were gender non-conforming
are homosexual just not right there were
lots and lots of ways to be a girl or a
boy
a woman or a man and none of those
different ways of being mean that what
you are revealing is that you're
actually the other thing you're not okay
you're not
so
returning to regressive expectations
about what it means to be a man or a
woman and if you don't play well with
the gender Norms of your Society well
then you have to be the other thing
wrong and regressive and really bad
especially for women
um if without breaking your flow I can
add a point there
I'm getting something from from what
you're saying that I hadn't seen before
just game theoretically speaking if we
take a bunch of stuff and we say hey
here's some guy stuff and then here's
girl stuff
and
as you point out in the 70s and 80s you
were free to do whichever those things
you really wanted to do and it didn't
cause anybody to question your sex right
right
um
if we now say well that's guy stuff and
we take every person who is born female
and is doing some guy stuff and has Guy
like instincts or whatever and we say oh
you know what that means
guess you're a boy right and so we force
some large fraction of those people to
jump the Gap into transition whatever
that is leaving on the female side
people who Express these more
traditionally female patterns
then the point is actually somebody like
you who encountered that world if you
arrive in that world after you've
already done that then the point is if
you want to be out there playing rough
and doing whatever right and you see
that the only people who get to do that
who are born female are people who are
trans and go through some transition
then the point is that becomes like a
um you know either you're gonna have to
go do a bunch of stuff that you didn't
feel like doing in the first place or
transition is the alternative it creates
a false that's a choice that's right and
it pushes you to thinking well the only
reasonable option here is to declare
myself trans because then I get access
to the stuff and there's something and
you know I'm talking about girls and
women who come to believe that they are
boys or men specifically
and um you know which is which is not
the sort of the predatory direction of
the trans problem the predatory
direction is the other direction but
it's also true that in modern times uh
many people would have you believe that
to be a woman is to um you know almost
inherently end up being raped
and you know the metoo movement which
could have been amazing and was
completely taken off the rails suggests
that you know everything is bad for
girls and women all the time the
workforce is you know replete with
sexism and groping and harassment and
you'll never get to the top and women
are paid less and it's it's exhausting
and terrifying and awful and like well
why don't I just become a man
's sake right why don't I just become a
man okay this is terrible and also I
don't even get to do the things I want
to do if I know that I'm this so I'll
just I'll just do that I'll just be that
thing and what isn't being said I mean a
lot of us are saying it's like
actually
um there's a whole lot of false
narrative out here you're being given a
whole lot of false choices that you
didn't have to make before and the one
that you're being pushed into is
actually not an option that's a that's a
failure to recognize basic
basic reality like you just you cannot
become a man
if you were born female you cannot you
can't do it you can't even have the
thing even if it's the thing that you
want right you can do something but it's
not it's not what you're being promised
right and the and the the people who I
think privately and I think they know
that I think of them as you know true
trans actually trans
um
I I I read them as I engage them as
the gender that they are living as even
though it is not the sex that they
actually are and they do not deny
biological reality
the people who are actually truly
struggling with a uh gender dysphoria
and and gender dysmorphia that ex that
is persistent and consistent and painful
and awful for them such that they really
feel that they need to live as the thing
that they are not the sex that they are
not even though they cannot ever
actually become the sex that they are
not
um are not the ones on the streets doing
the activism that's not that's not what
is happening so so I had something else
I wanted to add I'm imagining
a scenario in which a girl like you were
um
in modern times we just sort of
Transport your your situation into
modern times and a girl who is enjoying
doing stuff that's traditionally boy
stuff
um reveals this
and then gets a reaction from the female
role models in her world that is
predicated on the nonsense narrative
that's being pumped through the New York
Times
Scientific American the bite
Administration the Biden Administration
in which those females who should say
you know what's the natural thing to do
the natural thing to do is to be
supportive of this girl frankly there
may be a little good-natured chiding of
the fact that you're a tomboy I don't
think that's even out of keeping the
fact that a girl is you know hanging
with the boys is something that is
worthy of comment it's interesting and
so anyway this girl should be getting
feedback from her female Elders about
what she's doing what its implications
are obviously that's you know if she's
hanging out with the boys are probably
something she needs to know earlier than
she might need to know them otherwise
and instead of that
I'm imagining that these female role
models are suddenly going to have the
sense of okay
he's trans what does that mean well it
means we're in danger of a suicide if
we're not supportive right that is the
trump card that is used to sell this
whole thing to the point is okay nobody
do anything dumb all right we are
completely supportive of uh her
transness we are there for her a hundred
percent and so now we need to broadcast
that at her so that she understands
we're there we're going to get her
through this there's lots of help
available blah blah blah blah blah blah
blah and so the point is the feedback
that would ordinarily under any normal
circumstances at the very least even if
the girl thought she was trans be like
are you sure can we talk about this lots
of people have the sense that they are
one thing or another and it you know
naturally goes away in most people so
can we just you know slow down and
figure out what it means but but the the
somehow we've experienced a reversal of
the default assumption and the default
assumption isn't a a mild default
assumption the default assumption which
is that you're the sex you are I that's
the default assumption and the very very
very exceedingly rare thing which is you
know okay maybe you're intersex
extremely rare or you are the sex you
are but maybe you really are going to be
better off living life is the other
thing
we know some of those people because we
were teaching an extremely liberal
college right at the point that this was
becoming more of of a thing
most people
probably would never meet someone unless
they who was actually Trans in in that
in like in the true way unless they
happen to live in a small population
where there's a particular uh genetic
thing going on like as I mentioned this
little village in the Dominican Republic
um
so the fact that high schools
right one girl declares herself trans
and suddenly all of her friends
that's
um that's not trans no no that's social
contagion that's what that is that's
like anorexia and that's like cutting
and unfortunately that's like suicide
right like that that's those are the
things that we see spreading
contagiously through teen groups
especially female teen groups male teen
groups as well but female teen groups
and
um when it's anorexia or other Eating
Disorders or cutting
or God forbid suicide
we don't encourage it do we no we do not
encourage it
that would be Criminal
as so is the encouraging of this social
contagion that is happening so I want to
fill that in a little bit
um one the examples you mentioned are
exactly what you're saying Social
contagion is the right version of the
story there is another version of the
story in which the same pattern exists
but it's not inherently pathological
okay right so
we see lots of trends
trendiness is a thing especially in the
young right whether it's a trend about
you know how you wear your hair like hem
length uh whether it's the style of
music that you like or the style of
dancing that you're doing or you know
the expression you know nobody says
Daddy-o anymore so the point is
um
you never know anyone who did right no
we are too young for Daddio to have been
a thing so it was always hilarious it
was always the go-to but
um but the point is it is very natural
for uh social experiments in fact right
this is sort of Dawkins understanding of
what memes are is that they're these
like flashes of something spreading
horizontally across the population and
it can be very you know terrible stuff
like cutting or Worse
um or it can be benign stuff right like
the inflection of your voice or whatever
and so the point is that is a natural
feature of that age and we have taken
something let's talk a little bit about
why yeah well let's let's get there but
we have taken something in which the
consequences could not possibly be more
dire and long term right right you are
talking about committing this you know a
tattoo is bad enough right you get a
tattoo of something you thought was cool
when you were 15 and it's like oh God do
I have to live with that thing or get it
removed right but we're talking things
are low right the sticks the texture
sticks are low compared to you know what
I think I might be trans right and then
suddenly we're you know
permanently modifying you in a way that
actually takes functional stuff and
replaces it with at best a simulation
that isn't functional right this is in
no you know the whole well people are
becoming
people are becoming living avatars
that's it they are the online rules they
are aspiring
to
to be to be a facade to be an avatar
that will pass
and
um I mean especially the younger these
kids do this the more like they are
never to have experienced
their body as an adult the more likely
they are never to have experienced
sex with another human being
the more like they are never to have
experienced moving around the world and
seeing how it is that the world engages
with them as they are as opposed to as
they imagine they could be in their
heads and the idea that I know as
someone who is not yet even fully gone
through puberty
that I need to be a thing which I have
no empirical understanding of either
being a man or a woman because I'm too
young to have experienced either yet I'm
going to block my ability permanently
from becoming either
that's horrifying everyone is born
with very rare exceptions everyone is
born
such that they will become a man if they
were born a girl or a woman did I just
say that wrong a man if they're born a
boy or a woman if they were born a girl
and if you were born a girl you can't
become a man if you're born a boy you
can't become a woman and if you wanted
it differently I'm sorry like that you
just you can't have everything you want
that's not reality
so
by allowing children to block their
puberty
even that is sufficient
to if if they just stop it at that if
they're just on puberty blockers for a
couple years then and then something
intervenes like yeah actually I'm not
going to go on the cross X comments I'm
not gonna have the surgery even just the
puberty blockers will render them
less completely what they would have
been absent that ceasing of development
on some channels for some number of
years
because it doesn't just put you in
stasis
you we aren't metamorphic creatures in
the same way that a butterfly is but we
are developing along all of the possible
axes along all the possible domains
throughout especially throughout our
adolescence and puberty blockers slow
down some of it halt some of it don't
affect others of it and at the point
that you come off of it if that's the
only thing that you did
you might never obtain full fertility
you might never obtain your full form
that you would have you might not have
the same voice that you would have you
might not have the same behaviors and
brain that you would have and
furthermore no one including you will
ever know so this is a series of
experimental manipulations of humanity
for which there is no possibility a full
of a full understanding because the
intervention itself
prevents there being a control
so which brings us back to the question
of
uh
contagion being the pathological version
or just horizontal transmission of
culture in young people
and I think what I'm realizing is you
wanted to come back to the question of
why it is that things spread so readily
you know cultural traits spread so
readily in young people why we see that
pattern and I think actually this really
gets at something
uh new which is
there is a reason that Trends spread in
young people and a lot of the trends
that spread our nonsense and they're
triggered by you know advertisers who
are looking to manipulate the young into
spending money and so in some sense I
think we miss the importance of why it
is that the young are so susceptible to
um to patterns of behavior spreading
horizontally where that would be much
less likely to be true in adults
although maybe more so susceptible a
more apt word when it's uh pathological
Innovative perhaps when it's
um when it's creating a new cultural way
of being and is maybe this is where
you're going but is responsive to
actually I don't live in the world that
my parents did like the world is
changing such that I as an adolescent
need to look out into the world and say
this is this is my world to frame as I
need to understand it and what my
parents are telling me what my elders
are telling me about what is right and
good
may not be the best way forward if the
world isn't entirely static
so there was a documentary and
unfortunately because I didn't know we
were going here I I don't remember the
exact title it was a PBS documentary
called the was it the the merchants of
cool or something like that of cool was
definitely on the title and it was a
group of advertising folks especially
some folks who looked much younger than
they actually were who were part of a
project to figure out who the
trendsetters were amongst these
teenagers and to figure out what it was
they were doing that caused them to be
able to set a trend and then the
advertisers picked up on it and they did
that thing right yeah
um yeah and
essentially the trendsetters were you
know this will come as no surprise to
anybody who was paying attention as they
moved through that phase of Life the
trendsetters are very often the people
who are a bit insensitive to what people
think of them they do something and they
don't really care and the point is oh
that is kind of cool that's powerful
that you know you're gonna dress in a
way that if you described it to me I
might think was ridiculous but you're
sitting there in class and you don't
even care you don't you don't care how
people are looking at you that's that
speaks of power right and so
what what a we've got a bastardized
version of this because advertisers have
invaded every aspect of our lives and so
it's I think we're misled into feeling
that this whole Trend making apparatus
is all some kind of weird Shenanigans
it's a con at some level but that's not
it's inherent nature and if you imagine
a high school that exists you know if
you impose on it the structure of
civilization that existed 300 years ago
right where people didn't move very far
from where they were born typically then
the point is why would you be
susceptible to picking up a role that
was catching on in your little social
milieu as you were passing through that
age well in some sense your cohort is
about to emerge into adulthood and
inherit the power to run the place over
time
and you are establishing you know
everybody is picking a role and that
changes the roles available to everybody
else and so in some sense being
sensitive to oh what's working well if
that's cool in your cohort and your
cohort's gonna stick with that being
cool then it makes sense to be able to
play in in that no you right so anyway I
think in some ways this doesn't make any
sense in a giant Anonymous High School
where you're going to leave and never
see most of these people again but the
idea that you should be very sensitive
to you know as you point out you're not
going to live in your parents world
you're going to live in a new world and
in that world there will be rules and
you're discovering them as they form
amongst these people who don't yet have
power but are about to that it makes
sense to jockey for where am I going to
be who am I in that world and so the
point is you want a world it is natural
for human beings to experiment at that
phase of life for reasons that may not
make any sense anymore but are
nonetheless deeply built in the last
thing that you want to do
is sit there at the edge of the
playground
and look for one pattern that you're
going to decide is unlike all of the
other Trends you're going to ignore and
say ah that one's medical that's deep
psychological stuff we now have absolute
evidence this is a special kind of human
being that requires severe medical
intervention that will permanently alter
who this person is into the future the
point is no no that's like saying you
know okay you go get a haircut
and it's wild and people are actually
kind of cool with it you're like okay
that's your haircut for life right if it
was a haircut that would be bad enough
if you were stuck with something that
right bad enough
but now we're talking about actually
interfering with the opportunities that
the person will have physiologically
going forward that couldn't be crazier
yeah right it couldn't be crazier
um
it couldn't be crazier and yep and yet
both sides and in this case it really is
a both sides right it's it's it's it's
sides it's two sides it's not left
versus right liberal versus conservative
uh and it but it is there are two sides
and both sides
are convinced that they're on the right
side of History they're convinced we're
both convinced
um
so I said
that there's
one or more of at least three things
going on here with the with the rise in
so-called trans identity now it's the
it's um a return to regressive gender
norms
there's social contagion and there's
also some mental illness and
um
usually the mental illness is wrapped up
in the social contagion but the fact
um you know what you already mentioned
this but often you know parents are told
well if you don't support your child's
trans identity
their chances of committing suicide go
go way up uh and uh what is in fact true
because that's not
uh is that people who become convinced
that they are trans are separately
also very likely to have a number of
other diagnosable mental concerns such
as depression and anxiety and
um and and various other things that
have been named in the last 20 or 30
years I'm not trying to realize them but
so there's a lot of there's a cluster of
these sort of social anxiety things that
include even the darkest of the dark
um and that can sometimes lead to to
people committing suicide that are
clustered in among people looking for a
home looking for identity and looking
for identity is a large part of what a
lot of people are doing looking for
meaning and looking for identity in
adolescence right and
frankly I'm just like to be very honest
I don't I don't recognize from myself
nor do I remember
the friends that I had in high school
which included you
um focusing so much on like identity
like I was focusing on I was focused on
meaning like what what are we doing what
is this about how do I make meaning in
the world and how do I make it a better
place and make my life have had meaning
yeah and increasingly frankly it's a
move towards the narcissistic it's a
move towards the in interior like oh how
do I figure out who I am and how I'm
presenting to the world that's more
about identity and like there's always
there's always some of those
um but it does feel like we're
adolescents now are expected to be
focused on identity and not on meaning
and frankly I think if we move towards
more towards how is it that you can make
meaning for yourself and for the world
through your life rather than how is it
that you can make sure that everyone
knows who you are as you understand it
by making sure they get your made up
pronouns correct for instance
um is isn't that's not going to be
nearly as good a choice for you but
um
regardless of whether or not the the
anxiousness and the you know sort of
debilitating
um concerns about how the World Views
you that are so common now that are
associated also with the rise and
um
social media and cell phones and not
spending time moving your body and
outside and actually physically engaging
with your friends like in real space and
time uh it's
all of that is sort of a rise in mental
illness if you will and wrapped in the
social Contagion
we get people who have the one thing
that the guy on the side of the
playground in your in your vignette goes
like that's the one that we're going to
prioritize that's the one that we're
going to name and decide that that's not
social contagion that's not mental
illness that's the one that's not a
trend that's not a trend that's reality
that's a reality that all of humanity
until now has been missing we never saw
it before but suddenly
um suddenly in 2013 something like that
we're going to have this uptick and it's
going to be happening and press
secretary now
go ahead the press secretary now refers
to being to what is being done to
children as treatment
as in trans treatment
no no it's that's wrong it's not
treatment
we don't treat anorexia
by taking away food from anorexics and
telling them that they're fat
that's not how we treat anorexia
we don't treat people who cut themselves
by supplying with sharp knives and
private space in which to get in touch
with their feelings that's not how we
treat people who cut themselves
this is the opposite of treatment but
the con the confusion on yes the other
side is they are revealing their true
selves
they are they're screaming for help into
the abyss and if you don't listen to
them and honor their delusions then they
will kill themselves no
no there is separately suicidal ideation
among some people and those concerns
need to be dealt with but it is not this
way it's not this way so I want to add a
couple other things and then I want to
get back to what the press secretary
said and why
um but
not only are we identifying something
that might be a fad on a playground and
identifying as oh that person is
actually a victim of a kind of
Oppression that we are now morally
obligated all of us to support them in
something that we understand about them
etc etc but we are also
handing people who need two things from
us the inverse of the two things that
they need a we are handing them a weapon
with which to get that which they want
at this instant which they may in the
present context
urgently want and it may be their
parents obligation to say no honey I'm
gonna have to override you on this one
because that's my job my job is to
create the environment that makes you
into the adult that you can be and that
you want to be not to cater to what you
think you want as a child sometimes you
know what you want and sometimes you
don't and this is this is the time when
I need to say no so handing them the
idea that oh well if you allude to
Suicide then you get what you want right
a that's going to create terrible
parenting because the parents can't
counter it and B it's going to create
more suicide right it is going to turn
this into something an arms race where
they're going to have to be you know a
credible threat and a certain number of
people are going to lose their lives
because of the cynical Ploy yeah a
secondary contagion is being created by
the people who are claiming to be trying
to prevent just that right but they're
creating it they are creating it now the
other thing is and this is going to get
back to the press secretary in a second
but the
thing that people need imagine the
collection of truly well-intentioned
women role models who are encountering
the heather-like girl who is expressing
some boy-like preferences in the world
and are motivated to think oh God we
know who the good people have been in
history and who the villains have been
we're going to be the good people we're
going to be as supportive as we can yada
yada those people need to hear from
women who maybe did travel around more
like yours where they discovered
actually they could do whatever they
wanted right it's not even that you
chose a you know a male like life I mean
you have two kids you've done the mother
thing beautifully and you've also been a
you know a jungle biologist you've
chosen what you wanted you can do that
somebody needs to tell the girl who
discovers that she has some things she
wants to do that aren't traditionally
girl things but that's fine right and
the problem is that those who used to do
that right those women who are supposed
to be the role models for that girl who
is in need of advice might find you and
hear from you or somebody else who's got
a similar story right but they're not
going to because as soon as somebody the
environment the political environment
has been deliberately charged so that
you are not an authoritative Source on
this because do you know what else is
wrong with your perspective and then a
list of phony things that mean that
somehow you're a cryptic conservative
despite having never been a conservative
for a minute in your life right so I
don't follow the right science
I don't follow the right science that's
a doozy of a statement
um but yes it's exactly that is the
point is this is just creating an
environment
where everybody needs somebody to tell
them what they need to know rather than
what they want to hear and the rules
that mean that as soon as you start
listening to the person who knows what
you need to know and might tell you and
the point is well you're not experienced
are you listening to Bobby Kennedy Jr do
you realize he's an anti-vaxxer right
that thing causes you not to hear from
the person who has exactly the piece of
information that you need to learn well
there's two different I mean I think
there's two different things that you
just invoked there there's
um there's we're gonna we're gonna
attach Kryptonite to that thing whatever
it is whether it's you know me talking
about being a girl who didn't like to do
girl things or it's Bobby Kennedy Jr
running for president and getting no
traction because people go oh anti
right
um but there's that but there's also
I've just forgotten because I said
anti-vaxxer
um uh oh I forgot I forgot where I was
going all right uh hopefully it'll come
back to you in a second so I want to get
back to the press secretary and what I
think actually happened is at that
moment
uh sure yeah I've got a few more things
to do but but go go for it so here's
here's my concern
first of all press secretary is a very
special job it's the job I want least in
life all right it's an evil job it's a
job that uh you're paid to either be
stupid or lie through your teeth yeah no
and she I mean I looked a little bit
into her her background like she's had a
ton of interesting and reputable like
academic positions and you know this
that and the other so you know she
didn't she didn't come out of nowhere
yeah
nonetheless yeah the point is it came
out of her mouth yeah this is a ploy and
I think I know what Ploy this is and the
problem is that this is a ploy in which
both sides get what they want
so game theoretically it's a funny it's
a funny object
um so I want to give an example from
somewhere else there's a documentary
um
I forget it's it's a basically a new
atheist documentary in which there is a
scene in which Richard Dawkins confronts
a famous uh
creationist maybe intelligent design guy
and they have a little debate right if
you're a
sciencey person
Dawkins destroys him absolutely destroys
him but if you're a skeptic now Dawkins
is absolutely obliterated right and the
point is oh yeah they both delivered to
Their audience what so the point is they
both cryptically win I'm not saying I
don't Dawkins was not cynical in this
documents thought he won the debate he
did not understand that from the point
of view of the utility of the object it
changed nobody's mind right all it did
was feed each of their audiences exactly
what they wanted right now
this thing that came out of the press
secretary's mouth yeah is a clever
construction
designed to produce this reaction and
the point is sorry but like that that is
part of why I started with like I went
and scrolled through the comments like
not today Satan friends are communists
um they're saying the quiet part out
loud and like oh but of course you're
saying those things but aren't you the
same people who do on honestly want to
protect children right but imagine
imagine how this looks from I mean you
and I are blue dissidents so it's very
hard for us to actually feel what it's
like to be a blue believer at the moment
yeah but from a blue believer's
perspective here's what happened
the press secretary said something
actually just Noble and normal something
everybody understood
two years ago
and the conservatives are so crazy that
they actually thought it was demonic
right so what she said was the children
are all our responsibility right that's
not the exact quote but that's what
people who are New York Times readers
will have heard these are our kids they
belong to all of us they belong to all
of us my point is they belong to all of
us is the most beautiful Mott and Bailey
I've ever seen right there is an
interpretation of they belong to all of
us that is so obvious and so fundamental
to the way a civilization works that no
reasonable person could possibly
disagree with it and in the present
context if you say
the children belong to all of us
well not my [__] kids you keep your
hands off them right so it is
simultaneously the most obvious thing in
the world and the most aggressive attack
on children you can imagine and so both
sides you know the press secretary says
it she gets exactly what she wants and
whoever wrote that phrase they get
exactly what they want where the home
team just like yeah of course and then
the conservatives go
you can't possibly mean that and then
the blue team goes wait what's wrong
with those people are they really so
crazy they don't understand that we have
an obligation to Children right so no
and that's why that's where I started
right yeah so anyway my point is just
okay everybody can we stop being played
by these [__] they're not on any of
our teams yes right these people are
about their own power and what they're
doing is they're using children they are
cynically using children completely
indifferent to the harm done to them to
divide us right they're using children
to divide civilization so that they can
play their [__] political games and
they can win their power and they can
sell it to their real constituents that
have nothing to do with voters right
this is not about us and so it is really
important that we remember that
a yes
children are our Collective
responsibility the primary mechanism
through which we honor that
responsibility is through parents
right this is generally simple in
general one's parents has their own
children's interests at heart and we can
trust them to make the Judgment calls
we are now manipulating parents and
telling them they don't understand and
basically we're we're pulling a you know
the same kind of coup that public health
pulled on medicine right civilization is
now pulling on parents and it is telling
them you don't have the right to do
what's right for your kid yeah no and
teachers are acting like the doctors who
are captured by ideal ideological
nonsense during the pandemic right
everybody is because everybody lives in
fear of being on the wrong side of
History which I get in trouble for
sometimes for invoking the right and the
wrong side of History I'm a Believer in
these things but I'm not a believer in
them as in oh here is a right side of
history that you must be on my point is
we should all be trying to understand
how history will actually look at this
but this makes us terrifically
manipulable if we you know start taking
people's word for what the right side is
and we we have to avoid that
um yeah especially where children are
involved especially where children are
involved
uh so a couple more things related to
that and we could we could go on
indefinitely and I'm going to write
about a little something related in
Natural Selections this week so you'll
get more
um
in Florida and I did not
um I have not read the bill but um a
bill passed I think I'm not actually
even sure so this I just saw this last
minute before coming on air here
um that combines limits on abortion to
fetuses that are under I think 12 weeks
of gestational age with limits on
puberty blockers cross-ex hormones and
surgery for minors there's people under
18 who declare themselves trans now I
wish they hadn't combined those two
things in a single piece of legislation
um it doesn't it certainly doesn't help
uh the you know the vast number of us in
the middle uh who
um don't don't just uh vote by platform
or by party but who have different views
on different things but it is what it is
right so let's just focus for the moment
on that second part which has been
widely
um
portrayed as denying Health Care to
minors
denying Health Care to minors that's not
what it is of course but uh here we go
uh if you would put up my screen this is
and you know I don't have any idea who
this guy is he tweeted this thing I'm
putting it up um don't don't spam him
um he is tweeting about report out that
reports that says Florida Governor Ron
DeSantis signs Bill legalizing
anti-lgbtq plus medical discrimination
the law allows any medical provider or
insurer does not care based on ethical
moral or religious beliefs so again
that's not actually what happened
um
but this MD says I'm an emergency
medicine doctor when you come to my ER I
will take care of you even if your
beliefs are different than mine my job
is to take care of patients if you would
deny patient care because they have
different beliefs than you then you
should not be in medicine
um
that sounds again quite reasonable and I
think this may be
um I think in this case unintentionally
because this is just some presumably
good faith trying to do his best ER doc
who's making a claim that sounds utterly
reasonable and there were you know lots
of replies to him saying that's not what
the bill says no you're wrong you're
wrong you're wrong but the the part of
that that I want to take issue with
because I think it is a way of framing
this
deep and important disagreement that we
have in this country is his framing of
this as taking care
a doctor's job is to take care
parents job is to take care
the administration understands that its
job is to take care of those who cannot
take care of themselves
and
that's right right it's our job to take
care of our children and it's our job as
a society to take care of those who
cannot take care of themselves and it's
doctor's job to take care of people
that's why they come to doctors
but for me and for us and for many of us
this amounts to a fundamental
disagreement about what it means to take
care
right taking care of children again and
we already did this like you know
probably for over an hour at this point
we've already been doing this what it
means to take care of children is to not
let them
certainly not encourage them but not let
them make medical decisions that they
will never be able to undo at the point
that they are yet unable to understand
the implications of those decisions
what it means to take care is to protect
them such that they have as many options
open to them as possible in the future
which includes
being a fully fledged fully capable
fully able
human adult of whatever sex it was they
were born to that's what it means to
take care
all right
couple things
one
it is amazing to me how remote we have
become from the Hippocratic Oath
that there is something about the
Hippocratic oath and the Nuremberg code
that exists above job descriptions right
these things are I mean we don't say
oath lightly right not many jobs have an
oath right doctors have an oath that
oath
um is rather like the claim that one
should be very concerned about making
sure that they are on the right side of
History where it is easier to understand
the obligation than it is to
operationalize it what does it mean to
do no harm obviously a surgeon does a
certain amount of harm right and
hopefully the point is net good is
always the objective yep but nonetheless
there is an oath here and the surgeries
in question the puberty blockers the
intervention surrounding uh affirmative
so-called affirmative care which is you
know like vaccine a euphemism being used
to sneak something past us but the kinds
of interventions are very specific
specifically destructive of
non-subjective physiological function
right to go from a person that can
conceive a child as either a male or a
female and render them someone who
cannot conceive a child at all do we
talk about men conceiving children I
don't think so I think excuse that word
for men do we
uh if not I am going to bring this up at
the next meeting of the patriarchy and
we're going to get that changed because
suppose we agree that although men
cannot actually conceive children that
they have the right to conceive children
do we have to call you Loretta
um no but uh Stan would be fine in any
case
so let us I think the overarching point
is that this is actually at the
operational level
genuinely difficult stuff I don't think
the affirmative care stuff is genuinely
difficult I think the point is young
people are not in a position to know for
certain enough to get involved in any
medical intervention that has permanent
implications at that age
what's more
to the extent that there's any argument
against that parents have an absolute
right to do what is best for their
children in uh in blocking this even if
Medical Science declares that there's
some reasonable deployment of these
interventions parents have a right to
say absolutely no and schools don't get
any right to override that and
government doesn't get any right to
override that but I do want to point to
the genuinely difficult underlying stuff
here okay what when you first I did not
know that the uh abortion limitations
and the
um not allowing medical intervention for
minors who declare themselves trans
right were housed in the same bill on
the other hand when I hear that I
instantly get why that would have to be
the case it's you know I thought maybe
it's Sneaky political stuff but in this
in some sense
what DeSantis appears to be trying to do
is to carve out a mechanism where
doctors cannot be forced into
really diabolical medical interventions
right if Society is going to say well we
have to support these children in their
transition and that means that you have
to you know a agree that such a thing is
reasonable and B provide the medications
that set the children up and see you
know get them into the surgical setting
where this all happens if you're a
doctor who thinks you're talking about
mutilating children on the basis that
they learn something at school that made
them think for you know some period
during their teenage years that they
might be in the wrong body and I don't
want any part of participating because I
swore an oath that I wouldn't do that
sort of thing that doctor has to have
the right to say no right
and so I guess my point is as soon as
you recognize that that doctor has to
have the right to say no
in some sense you've recognized that
doctors have the right to say no and
obviously you and I are in a very
different place than DeSantis and others
on that side of the fence with respect
to the right to an abortion early in
pregnancy but I don't see a meaningful
difference between a doctor's right to
object to maiming children
according to this uh you know trans
belief structure that has so cynically
been foisted upon us and the right to
say no to participating in in that
process framed as you are
um
expert in a domain for which you went to
school for a very long time
you it is it is he it is within your
purview to decide whether or not you
will do
um some procedures and you know I guess
presumably
doctors have always had the right to say
actually I don't prescribe extra because
I actually know I actually know that
that drug is not what they're claiming
and I don't you come to my office asking
for that drug you're going to have to
find someone else I'm sorry I won't do
it and here's why and I hope you won't
either so uh
you know and I hope you won't find
someone else to do it because I really
don't think it's a good choice similar
with surgeries presumably I hope there
are doctors saying actually
um you know surgery for X isn't
something you should you should get so
oh you gotta
tear in your meniscus in your knees
meniscus and it's not one of these
bucket-handled tears it's going to be
snagging on you every time you move it's
just a little tear uh I overrode my
doctor when I had a little tear in my
meniscus when I'm not kidding surgery
for that I've had enough no I'm not
doing it and it was a much better choice
I wish that I had had a doctor who had
been what brave enough
to say hi why would you get surgery in
this case
uh so I assume that doctors have the
agency and I'm surprised that
um
I'm surprised that it is required that
there be
um some so I don't know like you and I
are not familiar with this bill well
enough so you're framing this as like a
doctor agency protector and I don't know
that we need a legislation for that so
I'm not at all sure that that's what
this is actually doing but in terms of
sort of understanding it philosophically
the two topics are linked because
they're both going to have a lot of
um
people will disagree strongly about
these two topics abortion
um so say second trimester abortions
because first trimester abortions are
still facilitated or allowed rather
facilitated aloud uh and not allowing
interventions to minors for people for
minors who think they are the sex they
are not
so I think you have just landed on a
very important uh piece of this puzzle
there's a phrase that has been ringing
in my ears since early in covet and I
have not quite figured out why it's
bugging me
it is standard of care
I believe doctors are less free than you
think because of the idea of standard of
care which I think standard of care is
going to fit on a list of objects that
seem obviously positive and it's going
to be a disaster and that list of
objects includes things like peer review
which turns out is not the same thing as
review by your peers it is going to land
next to things like evidence-based
medicine which is not the same thing as
following the evidence uh to the right
medical interventions there's a list of
these euphemisms that are used to
constrain the deployment of products and
procedures
and the thing about standard of care is
that
doctors have the right to prescribe off
label but the question is
if a drug is bad and the conventional
wisdom is that it is good how much
Freedom do doctors have to opt out of it
and what we saw with kovid was that in
the case of certain things that right
evaporates rather quickly there was no
opt out of something so there was no
opt-in to others right so that is an
almost perfect you know you had one tool
you could deploy and what's more you had
to deploy it
um and the whole thing would have
unfolded very differently if that had
not been the case but
so standard of care I have a feeling as
a rock that we're going to find a lot of
very creepy things under but the other
thing that I wanted to say is if you if
you look at the quote from the press
secretary
again it's a
beautifully constructed object to create
exactly this kind of Rorschach moment
but again these are our kids they belong
to all of us right they belong to all of
us which will be read by
blue team loyalists as they of course
they do they are the responsibility of
yeah it takes a village and it will be
read by the red team as oh uh they're
not really your kids uh leave them to us
which is in fact there's been an awful
lot of that in school and elsewhere
um but but here's my point okay
the children are all it is
civilization's responsibility to put
children first let's put it that way
that is actually true yep
parents are the way that we typically do
that right and parents are not
guaranteed to do a good job of this but
in general at least we know that a
parent's interests are in general
aligned with their own children whereas
the governments are not right the
government's interest can be exactly
counter to the children
um
so parents are the are the primary tool
but here's the here's the issue yeah
let's take an analogous situation that
has nothing to do with
um affirmative care or covet or any of
the other controversial stuff
in general parents have
as they should extraordinary rights to
decide what medical interventions to
expose their children to right the
Nuremberg code says you have the right
to informed consent in the case of a
child who is too young to be properly
informed and to consent to these things
the parent standard lieu of the children
and they must have informed consent but
this leaves us in a quandary with things
like I believe it's Christian Scientists
who don't believe in doctors
um I don't know maybe let's just say
that there's some small but significant
religious sect in which
uh I think the religious explanation is
effectively were you to interfere with
whatever God might be doing to you yep
right now the problem is do we
collectively have the right to intervene
on behalf of a child whose parents
believe such a thing and has a curable
but let's say fatal uh condition that
the parents do not want to treat right
I'm not saying I know the answer to that
my instinct would be that we have the
right to intervene but I'm not sure of
that because I I'm not sure that I want
to carve out that right in the face of
governmental structures that will
clearly abuse any opening and you know
drive a train through it right so I
don't know all I'm saying is Guess what
at the level of operationalizing the
principle that you are referring to this
is a genuinely difficult puzzle even if
the principle itself is perfectly
straightforward which it is yes there
are certainly
edge cases
ah this doesn't feel like one
I don't think it is
um
there are edge cases as you have pointed
out with regard to
um
you know life-saving interventions
um but then of course
there are many things that have passed
as life-saving interventions that have
turned out not to be life-saving
interventions and so the I you know the
those things that seem really really
clear
will not be clear to some people and
even some of the people for whom those
edge cases aren't clear
um not all of them are crazy right some
of them had an anecdotal experience that
is not something that is likely to ever
happen again but as a result they say no
way no how not that thing for any member
of my family because my cousin this
right well and it's oh it's challenging
I I would say this is the other you know
you and I have
um
talked in general terms about this
question
which is getting
less you know
we've talked about the question whether
or not the Amish are right right and the
short answer has been
not exactly but they may have the right
idea they may have spotted something and
picked an arbitrary moment to step off
the technological escalator but right
nonetheless doesn't mean it's the wrong
decision but I would point out
given the idea of metaphorical truth
that metaphorical truth means something
that isn't literally accurate but stands
in for a belief that you can't spell out
that is literally accurate the idea that
you know well who are you to interfere
with
God's you know physiological uh plan for
you
I don't think there's anything to the
idea that there's a God that has a plan
and so there's obviously lots of cases
where we can cure you of something if
you have uh an infection there's no
reason to let it go to gangrene if we
have an antibiotic that will cure it but
I would say that Traditions that are
extremely cautious about medical
intervention are looking more and more
prescient given the level of the
atrogenic harm that we are now seeing
covid being the
um the most distilled and concentrated
case where simply opting out of
everything the medical establishment
told you made you better off than
following any of it really well in some
ways I mean you you've found this for
for many many years but in some ways the
Apparently strange bedfellows that are
evolutionary biologists and the deeply
religious
where we find ourselves on the same side
of many issues increasingly which is
don't intervene until unless you
absolutely 100 know that you're not
knocking down a fence a lot Chesterton
that has a reason that you don't do not
yet understand
these these alignments between for
instance evolutionary biologists and the
deeply religious
are about
um recognizing that you know the origin
story is different we don't think it's
God we think it's billions of years of
evolution that have built things that
are much more complex than we can know
uh but there is a respect for
a set of forces if you will selection
God
um by which we can know that our that
our belief that we've simply got this
and we can change it and we're good
would be arrogant and the
interventionists which is to say most of
Public Health now most of modern
medicine like is flying on hubris they
are just it's all arrogance like we got
this this is not uh you know it's not
God we don't really get Evolution
whatever whatever we're going to fix
these things because we fixed it once
and it worked and we face it twice and
it worked and I didn't fix it that third
time but yeah things will happen and
those of us who are being cautious out
of a sense of you have no idea
you actually have no idea we are trying
to have an idea but we know the limits
of our understanding here that I think
is something that is shared between the
people who attribute their lack of
understanding to there is there is
another entity that has created this and
as has done it for a reason and those of
us who say we don't believe in the
entity but there are there are forces
specifically selection that have built
these these processes and these
structures and these systems over
literally billions of years and when you
mess with one you actually do not know
what all you are messing with
you know I had a uh conversation like a
two-hour conversation with Sev zelenko
shortly before he died
um he was one of the earliest and most
luciferous covet dissonance uh Orthodox
Jew
and it was a shocking conversation I
mean he was
um incredibly
thoughtful in his approach to all of the
surrounding issues and at the same time
uh deeply aware of very ancient roots of
proper medical thinking he he talked for
20 minutes about maimonides which is
something I I was not even aware wow
there were conclusions worth looking for
that far back but
um anyway the there is something it
doesn't really matter whether your
reverence for this comes from you know a
a love of the self-assembling biological
universe or from a belief that somebody
wanted this to happen right the real
question is you know or are you
motivated are you really rooting for it
and do you have a sort of
I mean you're right to point to
chesterton's fence do you really
understand how well constructed it is
and therefore how unlikely it is that
your intervention if it is anything but
simple and predicated on very secure
assumptions is likely to be positive
right do you have any idea how unlikely
you are to improve that thing
um and medicine is suffering from an
incredible arrogance in part because we
have this huge pharmacopia of molecules
nobody understands that we're tested
under conditions where the people who
own the patents we're also doing the
testing to see if they were safe and
effective right and so you know doctors
have this whole you know amazing medical
machine to throw at people who have some
sort of a complaint and it's you know
this is much of them throwing a really
sharp and heavy machine at people I mean
frankly people would be better off in
many cases right exactly all right you
get a little bruise but you know you
know that's not the doctor for you but
um but in any case it was interesting to
find yet another deep deeply religious
person who at the end of the day you
know you you
those who come from the secular side
often expect of the deeply religious you
know that they are inherently some sort
of
I mean I'm you know they're they're
quacks from somewhere else and the fact
is this is not
um this is not the experience right
these are people who yes have a
different fundamental understanding of
the universe but that motivation just in
the same way that parents are in general
aligned with the interests of their
children to an extreme degree to the
extent that you believe that there's
somebody who had this as a plan and that
you are part of that plan you're
probably motivated to be a pretty darn
good doctor yeah that's right
um
wow okay one more one more little thing
here related to some of what we've been
talking about
um did you hear about what the
editor-in-chief of I think she's the
editor-in-chief Scientific American did
this week
um yeah so here's here's the Tweet
um
based on an article an Audubon called
the fascinating and complicated sex
lives of white threaded sparrows on the
editored Scientific American says
white-threaded sparrows have four
chromosomally distinct Sexes that pair
up in fascinating ways PS Nature's
amazing PPS sex is not binary
well she got thoroughly and
appropriately dragged for this because
she's just dead wrong and you would hope
you would hope that the editor again I
forgot to look into it I think
editor-in-chief of Scientific American
would know that much basic basic basic
biology but apparently not because she
is now um
driving a ideological and political uh
Journal not a journal uh magazine not a
scientific one despite the name they're
not going to change the name I'm sure
because they called it political
American it wouldn't continue to get the
kind of readership that it does now but
um I mean everyone from Jeffrey Miller
to uh Colin Wright like a lot of people
you know accurately pointed out uh no no
uh there are four different
chromosomal organizations that yield two
different uh looks and strategies among
the males and two different looks and
strategies among the females and
strategy doesn't make sex no wrong so
um
that is I think all I'm going to say
about that right now and I may not even
refer to that but what I'm writing about
for my sub stack this week which I think
will be fun
um is about a system with which I am
very very familiar in which multiple
male strategies do not render all those
different strategies lots and lots and
lots of different Sexes no just like in
humans males can look a lot of different
ways and do a lot of different things so
too in as it turns out poison Frog's a
Madagascar and just as in humans females
can look a lot of different ways and do
a lot of different things and that
doesn't mean that we have eight
bajillion Sexes we have eight bajillion
however many it is on this planet at
this point individual human beings
you are all individuals even the ones
who claim not to be uh but you are one
or the other sex and
trotting out examples that are
interesting and unusual from non-human
animals like these right throated
sparrows with two distinct like Feta
typically distinct but still two males
types and two female types doesn't make
it four Sexes doesn't make it non-binary
by now she may or may not know that but
regardless I think the magazine is lost
like you know Nature and Science are
more important they're the actual
scientific journals they're lost
Scientific American is lost like where
are we supposed to talk about science
anymore well this is this is this
is batshit crazy and I use that
advisedly because you used to object
when people would claim things that's
just crazy I think I think the bats take
a lot of a lot of negative press and I
just they do yeah they've been blamed
for a lot of things lately yes they have
um but no you're you're absolutely right
and you know unfortunately the bad news
is that the new place where we
apparently have reasonable scientific
discussions is on podcasts which is a
terrible place I mean it's great to have
good discussions on podcasts but
obviously you know it can't help but be
the wild west yep
um so you know wouldn't it be geez I
wonder why somebody doesn't invent an
actual scientific journal
right wouldn't that be popular right or
an actual newspaper or an actual
University or you know an actual uh Free
Speech platform and lo and behold once
again we're back to zero it's a special
number right and the answer is of course
a single reliable scientific journal
that was not politicized would be the
premier journal on earth almost
instantly
um it doesn't happen because something
is preventing it because it also knows
that
that's right
okay I'm gonna um step off this
what slippery soapbox slippery soapbox
yeah and you had something yeah we've
gone on for quite a while I have one
more thing you have something that you
want to talk about I will try to make it
efficient
um so I'm going to return to the
question of Eleazar udkowski and AI we
talked last week about the I wasn't even
a full week ago was it
um yeah it was about the
shows what I know that's how you know
you and I have both been traveling this
week it just feels like less time that
doesn't even make sense
I know but I'm now caught up yeah a week
ago we spoke about the question of the
term dumers which I think is quite
unhelpful
um because lots of us who believe that
we are in very serious trouble as a
result of AGI
um Dawning whether it has donned or is
about to doesn't matter
um but lots of us who think that there
is very serious Jeopardy to humanity
from this
would be outside of the limits of what
that term apparently refers to which is
utkowski and uh others who see the world
as he does who think that the likelihood
of our complete Extinction is extremely
high if we do not take utterly drastic
action
including a pause on all research on
large language models
and extreme governmental authority to
enforce that Globe wide including things
like air strikes on server Farms that
participate in experiments that are
unauthorized Etc so
the reason I bring it back up
is that an exchange unfolded on Twitter
uh yudkowski
responded to a clip of us talking about
an example that he deployed in which he
had argued that the AI might order up a
virus that would uh infect
a large fraction of the human population
by being very contagious while not being
highly virulent that it would make a
small modification to the brain such
that people would become highly
susceptible on uh playing of a certain
tone
I took him to task I said
um there's lots of bad things that can
happen here that's not one of them and
that he has some obligation if he's
going to say look there are lots of ways
that this could go very very wrong that
he has to deliver examples that are
plausible and that when it comes to
biology I just think he is displaying
that he misunderstands so Zach do you
want to show the
so here Eliezer
says
at Brett Weinstein one what is your
understanding of my claim that a super
intelligence could design a virus that
would rapidly propagate through a large
chunk of the population to what do you
think is impossible about your version
of that claim
okay now that is not
what I was objecting to I tried to be as
complete as I could inside of a single
tweet and I said quote design won't work
in the foreseeable future but
uh specify modifications to existing
viruses is clearly possible just ask
ecohealth Alliance who participated in
work that did just that which very
likely escaped the lab and Wuhan
creating the coven pandemic is what I'm
alluding to I continued
the part I found Preposterous was that a
virus leads to cognitive control of all
infected or post-infection humans that
doesn't square with reality Eliezer
responds he says why not
toxoplasmosis is not a thing question
mark no virus can possibly damage or
modify brain structures I don't get what
you think you know can't happen he
continues is your objection more like
one it is not physically possible for
there to be such a thing as a viral
syndrome that EG damages the amygdala
and modifies the auditory nerve or two
not even a super intelligence can design
or if you weirdly prefer modify a virus
which does we won't continue his tweet
you want to go to the next screenshot
you can't really response was smaller
um I think I can almost get it let's
skip the one on the top there so Le eyes
are oh no so another account yeah
another account responds from Brett's
video quote the idea that it is going to
produce a novel novel biota that is
going to embarrass natural selection
this is a dead end the AI is constrained
to the same biological logic that
creatures are
um I think that this is closest to one
of two the biologically impossible
alternative that Eleazar spells out
elieza responds cool then it should be
no trouble for Brett Weinstein to tell
us uh those key facts of which I am
ignorant by which it is known to him
that a super intelligence may not do
that I mean no more do this no more do
this than travel faster than light
okay I will not continue reading his
tweet I think that's the substance of it
then I respond stunning that you think
it's a matter of facts about which you
are either aware or not your
understanding uh your misunderstanding
fundamentals of a complex process and
projecting into the Gap logic about a
roughly analogous complicated process
while demanding action that is sure to
increase the risk
he says okay so you don't actually know
of any reason a super intelligence can't
build a virus that infects a lot of
people in a month or why that virus
can't tweak brain structures next
screenshot
okay
um then another account uh yair Levy
responds Brett respectfully this is the
mother of all event Horizons and if
you're not true and you are not treating
it as such
um I respond to him I wish that was the
case but the difference in our
perspectives apparently leads to a
nearly to nearly opposite prescription
so I don't think it's minor at all
uh Eric tornberg responds you and
Eliezer yukowski should discuss this on
Dark Horse or some other discussion
forum happy to be helpful I said I'm
willing could be very productive and
then as far as I know no response from
Eliezer
um I can't remember what the last one is
no
you show it
oh okay this is uh yair Levy again I
hope I'm pronounced sorry that's hard to
read at this distance
um who
uh quote tweets a wittenstein quote
wichtenstein is a favorite of mine
actually and the quote is when I hear
people arguing uh
uh so this is this is uh Lavi talking he
says when I hear people arguing about
what a super intelligence could or could
not do I'm immediately reminded of
liechtenstein's
uh victinstein's Immortal words whereof
one cannot speak thereof one must be
silent okay all your speculations are
meaningless here
okay so was he speaking to you yes yeah
so first of all I want to respond to him
and say this can't possibly be
meaningless if the prescriptions if the
thing about which we are differing
results in a near inversion of what we
think the right course of action is if
two people who believe that we Face
something very serious and that we must
take the most reasonable action going
forward disagree on what that action is
then settling small differences like
this is apparently important well it
also seems like you know this is
you hadn't shown me these before
um the Wittgenstein quote seems to be
taken and it's like sensustrikto
narrowest sense that is
um to again as yukowski suggests be
looking for just the facts just tell me
what I need to know and then I'll go
ahead and do it which entire and I I
don't I'd have to remind myself of all
of what fitzgan did but I don't think
that he was actually a sensu stricto
sort of a thinker he was much more he
was much more expansive and I don't
think that he would have read his would
have interpreted his own words here to
mean if you can't tell me exactly
prescriptively what it is that will
happen FX then then we we ought not be
talking about it or I don't remember
exactly what the end of the quote was
um so I mean it feels to me like you and
yukowski are having a um well it's
frankly it's a biological it's a
biologist versus Engineers understanding
of the universe it's a complex systems
versus machines understanding
complicated system versus complicated
systems understanding of the universe
and you know what you are saying and
what we have we have said also is
just because this was created and is
therefore a complicated system doesn't
mean that complex systems aren't related
to what is going on here and your
misunderstanding your your failure to
recognize the role that complex systems
would play means that you will misstep
and so as I think what yukowski has done
is he said oh I'll just take some of the
complex system stuff over here and make
it do the thing I wanted to do it's like
you've conflated complex with
complicated is that is that he's
conflated complex with complicated and
there has been a radical but subtle
inversion of the burden of proof as a
result of this right he's saying can you
prove this is impossible right and the
point is that in no universe is that my
obligation you have alleged something it
doesn't square with the biology right
and his Focus I'm not going to get too
deeply into this because at the end of
the day I think we need to have that
conversation and we need to have it out
because and I will say this up front
if you are correct Eliezer I want you to
win that debate I have children
I have an interest in them having a
planet if you're right I want you to win
the debate but if I'm right you should
want me to win the debate because it
changes what we ought to do that matters
a great deal and so
um
there is a lot to say about
a is invoking the facts his inverting
the burden of proof
these things speak to whatever I believe
he is making I'm certainly aware of
toxoplasmosis and we'll be happy to talk
about its uh relationship to this puzzle
you know it certainly does suggest that
the modifications of behaviors by
pathogens are readily possible that you
know it was well known to me when I
weighed in on this discussion of course
and I can come up with a bunch of other
examples if you'd like them but the
question is from courtesy right from
cordyceps you talk about rabies we can
talk about all sorts of things
um but nonetheless I think we have to
have that debate and
um I don't know whether it is necessary
as possible in light of the difficulty
of even following the threads on Twitter
given the way replies
make it hard to find things it's
possible Eleazar didn't see that but I
suspect that he just basically walked
away from the discussion with oh well
then you don't have the goods do you and
that forces me to take
I mean they're Desperate Times Desperate
Measures are warranted I'm going to take
drastic action oh god
um perhaps you should sit down
just like another floor
um Ellie azer I double dog Daria to talk
about this with me oh no you didn't oh I
did and I did okay there's no going back
from that so flagpole at three o'clock
um or I don't know somewhere
um I don't know I'm uh I'm not good at
this but uh but hopefully we could have
a very productive discussion I would uh
in all seriousness say I don't love the
idea of debate I think debate is
pointless I think dialectic is the way
to do it but most people don't really
have a relationship with that concept so
debate might be a decent shorthand but
let's just have a discussion about what
this is and why why you come to the
conclusion that you do and why I come to
a different one and what part we agree
on and why the prescriptions differ so
radically
great I
takes you up on it
happy
yeah there are far too many topics which
seem to pose existential threats at the
moment and uh certainly large language
models are one of them is one of them be
one of them
large language models are yes
um but they've won R1
R ones are where all the people wrong
okay okay I almost descended back into a
random app peer review yeah
um all right I think we are we are done
we are done and I I do need some sleep
which I will get at some point I don't
think so wow
all right
um we are not gonna do a q a today we'll
be back next week uh with some new stuff
new places to be uh new things on offer
uh in the meantime uh consider joining
um joining us on our patreons where you
can get access to the Discord server
read our book hunter-gatherer's Guide to
the 21st century and my Natural
Selections which is natural
selections.substack where I'll be um
writing about uh different mail
strategies and how that doesn't mean
that you have multiple more than two
Sexes uh this upcoming week and until we
see you next time and forever be good to
the ones you love eat good food and get
outside be well everyone
[Music]
thank you
foreign